That's a very interesting question.
I don't think that one can say as a
blanket statement that America,
I'm an American.
I think there are parallels in both.
Um,
there are,
there are parallels in too much trust in
government and I think you saw that to
some degree in the 19 sixties with
America's legacy in entry intervention
to Vietnam and even to I think to a
slightly lesser degree,
you saw that with the wake of Iraq after
a period after nine slash 11 when
Americans were more trusting of their
leaders and wanting to believe and then
follow their leaders.
Um,
uh,
so they're excessive trust can be
dangerous,
particularly when it leads to the
congress and the judiciary and the press
being complacent,
uh,
in their,
in their acceptance of the official
version of events.
I'm,
on the other hand,
I'm too radical a distrust,
um,
can prevent government from being able
to function a effectively that,
that public leaders publicly,
you want public leaders to earn people's
trust by being honest with them,
by being effective in what they do.
Because unless the government is a
government is able to earn some degree
of public trust,
it is not able to bring Americans along
the hard decision.
So it was very important in Franklin
Roosevelt taking American to World War
Two that he was able to bring to develop
the trust of the American people.
Um,
obviously Pearl Harbor made,
made a,
made a big difference in our entrance,
in the world of throughput that the
Franklin Roosevelt was very shrewd about
recognizing the degree that he had to
build trust in the American amongst the
American people,
and a mix even amongst people of the
opposing party,
which is why he systematically brought
Republicans and political opponents in
to work with him on foreign policy in
order that he could maintain the trust
to bring Americans to do something which
was very difficult.
Which to send our troops again into a
European war.